hi i'm patricia heaton and this is my
mother load
[Music]
i just have an issue with keeping
schedules and times
straight in my head and my kids are very
aware of this and the worst
time that i messed up a schedule is when
my son went away to a music camp
for two weeks i checked in with him
every weekend i drove up one weekend to
see him making sure everything was okay
and told my other three sons now we all
are driving to see
john's concert at the end of the two
weeks
and it's saturday it's sunday and we're
all gonna go do it
saturday night i'm driving one of my
sons to drop them off at a bar mitzvah
and i get a call from john at camp
saying you guys come to the concert and
i'm like yes we're so excited we'll all
be there tomorrow
and he said it's right now and i was
like what do you mean it's right now i
thought it was tomorrow he said no no
it's like
right now and i said can they hold it
off for like a minute and he said i'll
ask him
and i called my husband and i said i'm
driving
up to john's camp right now for the
concert
and so i just went from the bar mitzvah
up the mountain
it was like in big bear or something
like arrowhead
i'm on the way calling him going have
you started he's like we're going in
right now we're starting concert
i kept driving and driving and he called
me back and he said
the concert's over and i'm like i'm so
sorry i have another 30 minutes till i
get there i drive and drive and drive
and he calls me back and said how much
longer because everybody's parents have
picked them up
and taken them home and i'm the only one
here and all the counselors are sitting
here
waiting for you to come it was like tell
him it's another 30 minutes
so i finally get toward the camp i said
where are you he goes the counselors
finally took me to the restaurant with
them because they were tired of waiting
for you
and so i had to go pick him up at a
mexican restaurant
he was standing there with the suitcase
i missed the concert that he had
practiced for
two weeks he was so proud of it and none
of us
saw it uh i cried
like the whole way driving there so
that's my very
happy mother download and by the way to
this day i
still can't keep these blinking
schedules straight in my mind it's like
it's like math it's like white noise
it's just it never computes